Could you explain how you don't, you don't have Hpilora.
You don't. So, you're, so you could do whatever I explained those three tests for Hpilora.
You read a threat test, you could do a blood test for Hpilora, you could do a stool sample test.
If all of those are negative, it still doesn't lead, you don't have Hpilora.
So, you could have Hpilora that's harboring underneath your endothelial tissue in the smooth muscles of your arteries.
And it's never going to show up on a blood test and it's never going to show up on a stool sample test.
It's definitely not going to show up on a urea breath test.
So, well, how do you transfer that? Well, unless you were going to go and do a biopsy of that tissue. Well, actually, that's how they found that out.
So, it would actually study doing post-mortem biopsies.
So, people that died of heart disease, they did post-mortem biopsies of where the damaged, the vascular tissue was, where the occlusions were.
And they found Raleia burgodorpine, which is also a gram negative bacteria, Hpilora, a gram negative bacteria.
Heavy metals and a couple of things to get rid of the study now.
But those were there in the presence of almost all of those patients.
So, Hpilora is a big player, gram negative bacteria are big players, because gram negative bacteria have label polysaccharides in their cell membrane, which make them even worse bacteria.
So, because when you do kill them and liberate label polysaccharides, which are larger enough to, to create an immune response, which can be deadly, you'd dependent on where it is.
So, it's, it's best to just treat yourself for Hpilora on a regular basis, honestly.
Well, how would I do that? Well, it's using things like that are in our pair of clear.
Apex makes it HPLR specific for that. There's number of different companies that make things to kill Hpilora.
Burberry is one of the best things to kill Hpilora.
Burberry is really good to kill Hpilora.
This things actually work really well and work better than the antibiotics.
So, no side effects except if you're out of blood, that are you get to be taking polymeric.